منذ بدايه الصراع الصواريخ الاتيه من قطاع
غزه والقتال المحتدم عبر الحدود مع
اسرائيل كان الجيش الاسرائيلي يعول دائما
على القبه الحديديه لكنه اليوم ولاول مره
يستغني عنها ويستخدم منظومه جديده
منظومه سماها مقلاع داود فما هي هذه
المنظومه
مقلاع داود ونظام صاروخي قصير ومتوسط
المدى وهو جزء من الدفاعات الصاروخيه
الاسرائيليه التي تشمل نظام الصاروخيه
الشهيره القبه الحديديه لاعتراض الصواريخ
القصيره المدى ونظاماي ار 2 وارو ثلاثه
لاعتراض الصواريخ الطويله المدى وكاله
كشفت ان الجيش الاسرائيلي استعان بهذه
المنظومه لاول مره حيث اعترضت صاروخا كان
متجها صوبه الابيب في عمليه ناجحه هذه
المنظومه تصنعها شركه رافائيل لانظمه
الدفاع المتطوره الاسرائيليه صحيفه يدعيوت
احرنوت اشارت الى انه في عام 2018 اطلقت
المنظومه صاروخين لاعتراض صواريخ اطلقت من
سوريا صوب اسرائيل لكنها سقطت داخل
الاراضي السوريه
الاعتراض الصواريخ التي يتراوح
التي تحلق على ارتفاع منخفض وكذلك
الصواريخ الموجهه وصمم ايضا لاعتراض
صواريخ كروز
فيما يبلغ سعر الوحده منهم مليون دولار
وتكلفه المنظومه كامله تبلغ
345 مليون دولار امريكي
مقارنه بقبه الحديديه التي يبلغ سعر
بطاريتها فقط 50 مليون دولار فيما تم
الاعلان عن بدء تشغيل مقلاع داود في ابريل
سنه 2017
يتكون مقلاع داود من صاروخ متعدد النبضات
يستخدم اجهزه استشعار وانظمه تحكم
المتطوره ومجموعه ناشطه ممسوحه ضوئيا
ورادارا متعدد المهام للاستهداف والتوجيه
مسؤولون اسرائيليون قالوا ان مقلاع داود
سيكون بمثابه مكمل لنظام القبه الحديديه
المستخدم في الصراع مع غزه حيث انه سيمنع
الصواريخ التي اثبتت انها سريعه وقويه
للغايه بالنسبه للقبه الحديديه يذكر ان
وزاره الدفاع فنلنديه قامت بصفقه شراء
مقلاع داود الاسرائيلي بعد انضمامها
للناطق في ابريل عام 2023 بتكلفه شراء
بلغت نحو 345 مليون دولار بهدف تعزيز
قدراتها الدفاعيه